on the 14th of April 2020 Matt Hancock
was on his way to the Daily covid Press
briefing but according to WhatsApp
messages published by The Daily
Telegraph the same day he was also
messaging civil servants about an urgent
recommendation
from chief medical officer sir Chris
witty that all people being admitted to
Care Homes should be tested for covid at
this point in the pandemic both men knew
how grave the situation in Care Homes
was deaths from the first wave of covert
had hit their Peak on the 10th of April
the vast majority of them nearly 20 000
in that wave were care home residents
yet it appears when the whatsapp's
published that Mr Hancock rejected the
cmo's advice replying he'd rather leave
out Community testing adding it muddies
the waters
the former Health secretary has now hit
back a spokesperson saying key elements
of the messages had been omitted which
showed he'd supported sir Chris whitty's
advice his former colleague the social
care Minister said something similar to
The Commons earlier I should mention
that selective Snippets of WhatsApp
conversations give a limited and that
time's misleading insight into the
Machinery of government at the time Mr
Hancock said the reason for not
following the cmo's advice was that
there wasn't sufficient covid testing
capacity available at the time of the
WhatsApp exchange there was only
capacity for around 70 000 tests a week
but within two weeks it was about to
grow exponentially
something those involved at the time say
ministers would have been very aware of
I would find it impossible for someone
seeing it at dhsc to suggest that they
weren't the position to know
that there was going to be a significant
change in PCR testing capacity in the
next two weeks at that time
messages published by the telegraph
employment to Hancock's reluctance to
scale up Community testing was due to
his desperation to hit his Target of a
hundred thousand covert tests a day by
the end of April I am now setting the
goal of 100
000 tests per day by the end of this
month
that is the goal and I am determined
that we will get that as the deadline
loomed he messaged then evening standard
editor George Osborne declaring I want
to hit my target
are the messages evidence of a health
secretary being Guided by politics not
the science or tidbits Cherry Picked by
journalists with their own agenda well
that's one reason we have inquiries in
response to the revelations the UK
covert inquiry said evidence like
WhatsApp messages has been requested
from all key Witnesses
if one former minister's phone archive
contains explosive details there are
many many more to come Tom Clark Sky
News